نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤول قطري قوله ان
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ابلغ عائلات ست
رهاء امريكيين واسرائيليين بالدوحه بان
مقتل صالح العاروري عقد اكثر جهود تامين
اتفاق جديد واضاف المسؤول ان رئيس الوزراء
القطري اطلع عائلات الرهائن الامريكيين
والاسرائيليين السته على تحديات تواجهها
الوحه في جهود التوصل لاتفاق جديد ونقلت
اكسيوس ان رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري ابلغ عائلات الرهائن بان
التحدث مع حماس اصبح اكثر صعوبه خصوصا بعد
ما حصل في بيروت ونقل ونقلت اكسيوس عن
المسؤول القطري قوله ان من الصعب بشكل
متزايد الحفاظ على قنوات الاتصال مع حماس
بسبب تصعيد القصف في غزه واماكن اخرى y